Hey, everyone.
So there was a really good tweet at
the end of last week
from Steve Wade
who was curious what people are doing when
they use a get ops deployment architecture.
And how they alert if there's something running
in their cluster that wasn't deployed
through the automation.
And that could be either a bad actor
deploying something into your cluster, which is obviously,
you know, definitely something you wanna alert on.
Or even just a developer
who is messing around in production. And
although what they're doing might be okay, still
usually best to purchase a warning or something
in a Slack channel.
And what I replied with was
how I would do this, which is what
I'm gonna try and demonstrate just now.
So my suggestion was that through whatever your
continuous
deployment or get up space architecture as well,
that'd be through a customized cube CTL on
its own
or RLCD is that all of these tools
will allow you to inject some sort of
annotation or label onto all the resources.
And you could just use the GET shaft
which might
be useful over time.
And anything that doesn't have that label or
annotation
is something not controlled by
your automation.
So
what I have is a repository here,
InfluxDB examples.
This is on GitLab and GitHub. Regardless of
that, the username is Rawkode.
The repository repository name is InfluxDB dash examples.
And inside of that, there is a Kubernetes
folder which is a demonstration of how to
use InfluxDB
for complete
monitoring experience
of Kubernetes.
Now there's a couple of caveats to the
demos I'm doing just now. And the first
one is that I'm having to compile Telegraph
from the master branch because of a new
feature that hasn't had the one thirteen release
yet, but will be part of one fourteen.
And that is the ability to take the
labels
from any resource
and add those to your metrics you store
in InfluxDB.
So here, I'm just saying don't exclude anything
and only include the gitops.com/sha
label on resources.
So this will store all of my pod
metrics and analytics DB and add on this
label if it exists.
And the automation to do that is here.
Feel free to take a look if you
wish.
Beyond that,
I have
this Kubernetes YAML and
this is going to create a GitOps namespace,
deploy NGINX and we're gonna we're gonna pretend
this was through my automation. So I've added
a label here called gitops.com/share.
And we also have a second deployment which
does not have any sort of getops.com/share.
And this is the one that we wanna
alert on. We wanna send some sort of
message to Slack that says, hey, this is
running in the cluster.
Doesn't look like it was managed by our
automation.
So if we take a look at our
cluster,
you can see on this bottom tab, I'm
just port forwarding to InfluxDB so I have
access to the web interface. And up here,
I have k nine, which is just a
two way tool for introspecting
your Kubernetes cluster.
And we can see that we have
our telegraph notes, which is the one we
built for master running and collecting metrics.
We're also scraping previous targets for a different
configuration. We also do some control plane monitoring.
And then all the other regular
Kubernetes stuff you would expect to see.
If I come up here, we can take
a look at the InfluxDB
UI.
So I can come into the data explorer
and these are all of the metrics that
are being fetched by the telegraphs.
You know, the only one I really am
interested in just now is our pod metrics.
We're gonna filter by namespace and we're gonna
take a look at everything we get back.
And you can see we've got some stuff
coming through. So we feel the raw data
here.
You can see the collection interval.
We can see the value depending on the
fields. So we've got some log fs and
memory stuff, etcetera.
If we just go back up to the
calling headings, we can see we have container
name, we have this label that we're being
we're having pulled through by Telegraph
as well as the host, the namespace, the
node name, and the pod name.
So of course, in our real production infrastructure,
I would have wider
context
here with many more columns. But for now,
this is gonna allow us to kind of
look at how this would work within InfluxDB.
So what's really
important
now is that we wanna be able to
alert
when this doesn't exist.
Now InfluxDB two has some really cool features
built in for this,
and we're gonna use one of them called
tasks,
which is just a flux script that are
run on any given interval
and introspector metrics and allow you to do
something.
So what we're having here is we're gonna
see this is the get ops alert task.
It's gonna run every one minute
and it's gonna look at our metrics and
try and determine something.
Now because of the awesome work by some
people in the InfluxDB team,
there is
a
manifest format that resembles a Kubernetes manifest format
that allows you to deploy
any InfluxDB resource to your InfluxDB
instance.
I'm not gonna use the tooling for that.
I'm just gonna copy and do it through
the UI so that we can
see it running very quickly, but you could
do influx package dash f point it to
this the same way you would with Kube
CTL. So really, really cool setup.
Will talk through the flux script as I
go here, but
the first thing I wanna do is import
http and JSON
so that I can send alerts.
And then because it's a time series data,
we have to specify a bucket and arrange
to read from. So all of my telegraphs
are configured to write metrics into Kubernetes.
Because my task runs every one minute, my
range is only gonna be one minute. So
I wanna take a look at the previous
minute to see if there were any new
pods I should be alerting on.
And just as I did that through to
the data explorer UI,
we
can just do the filters and our Flux
task.
So I only care
measurement that is about the pilots.
I'm only gonna look inside the get ops
namespace. The reason I'm doing that is just
to simplify this demo.
Of course, there are things in the cube
system namespace that aren't gonna be deployed through
your automation or what have those shares.
So you should really build that into your
query
or provide a way to put those labels
on it. That's up to you.
The other filter I wanna do here is
just say, only show me records pulled out
from the
from the bucket that do not have this
column.
And then go to group by pod name
and just grab the first one and then
map over it to then stand by message.
So I'm just constructing an arbitrary object here
a message that says, oh, look, there's something
unexpected in our cluster.
I'm gonna add on the context that I
have available. So that's the pod name, namespace
and node name.
And I'm not going to post this to
Slack
because I don't wanna share any keys online
or even just have Slack running just now.
So I'm gonna use our books.app,
which is a really
cool
I don't know.
Fake HTTP end oh, real HTTP end point,
but this takes any arbitrary request that you
send to it and then shows you in
a browser.
So I'm just gonna copy this
and update that.
And then we're just gonna JSON encode the
object we created above and then I'm just
gonna return
this.
And that's just gonna satisfy the data explorer
because one thing I can do is copy
and paste this
and run it real time as well as
through the task. So we'll save this.
We can see view task runs and within
the next minute, a task run will show
up here to show us that it ran.
From the data explorer, we can switch to
the script editor,
paste on this exact same task only.
I'm gonna comment out the HTTP post because
we only want that to happen in a
task.
And we can see that we do have
something coming back and that's because we have
that fake or unmanaged
deployment running in our cluster.
And if we just view the raw data,
we can see all the information that we're
gonna expect to see on our HTTP alert.
I come over here and I hit refresh.
We don't have a test run yet. So
we're gonna have to wait for thirteen
forty seven roughly.
Oh, actually, we just caught forty six. Perfect.
Even better.
And if I jump over here
and hit refresh,
you can see that our alert triggered, sent
an HTTP post request to our box and
we can see that we've got an unexpected
pod running in our cluster
and the get ops near space on this
node with this pod name.
And that's it. That's how I would alert
using InfluxDB,
the flux language, and
to detect unmanaged
unmanaged
resources and my Kubernetes cluster.
That's it. Thank you very much for watching,
and I'll try and do more of these
in the coming days and weeks. Cheers.